digamos que tenemos una bolsa llena de
pelotas de colores y sabemos que el 40
por ciento de dichas pelotas son de
color anaranjado vamos a definir una
variable aleatoria x cuando metemos la
mano a la bolsa y elegimos una pelota de
forma aleatoria observamos su color lo
anotamos y regresamos la pelota a la
bolsa la variable aleatoria x será 1 si
elegimos una pelota anaranjada o 0 si
elegimos una pelota de cualquier otro
color quizá ya hayan reconocido esto
como una variable aleatoria de
bernouilli y podemos determinar una
distribución de probabilidad para esto
vamos a hacerlo x es discreta pues sólo
puede tener dos valores 0 o 1 y sabemos
que el 40% de las pelotas son de color
anaranjado entonces el 1 tiene una
probabilidad del 40% de ocurrir y hay
una probabilidad del 60 por ciento o de
0.6 para obtener un 0
esta es la distribución de probabilidad
de x estamos haciendo este repaso porque
vamos a hablar de
concepto de distribución muestral el
cual puede confundirnos un poco ya que
estamos acostumbrados a pensar en
términos de distribuciones de
probabilidad y no en términos de
distribuciones muestrales lo que hacemos
en la distribución muestral es comenzar
con una población después tomar una
muestra de dicha población
esta es la población y esto otro es una
muestra de la población la muestra debe
tener cierto tamaño digamos que es n y
después calculamos una estadística de
esa muestra finalmente vemos la
distribución de las estadísticas que
obtuvimos de las muestras seguimos
tomando muestras de la población
calculando su estadística
hacemos esto varias veces digamos que
esto lo hacemos un número infinito de
veces
ahora gráfica mos la distribución de
estas estadísticas y entonces tendremos
la distribución muestral veamos esto de
forma más clara con el ejemplo que
tenemos aquí de las pelotas de colores
vamos a encontrar una distribución
muestral tenemos la población y sabemos
que el 40% de esta población es d
color anaranjada aunque muchas veces
desconocemos los parámetros es muy común
estimar los parámetros al observar las
muestras el tamaño de cada muestra es de
10 pelotas cada vez que tomemos una
muestra calcularemos la estadística de
cuántas pelotas son anaranjadas en la
primera muestra tenemos tres pelotas
anaranjadas como la muestra es de 10
tenemos un 30% de pelotas anaranjadas
para la segunda muestra tenemos dos
pelotas anaranjadas es el 20% seguimos
haciendo esto y eventualmente podremos
graficar una distribución de las
proporciones de las muestras nos quedará
un tipo de distribución discreta y la
forma de interpretar esta distribución
discreta es veamos suponiendo que este
valor de aquí es 0.15 decimos que hay
una probabilidad del 15% de obtener una
muestra donde el 50% de las pelotas sean
de color anaranjado o si este valor es
de 0.07 hay una probabilidad del 7% de
tener una muestra con un 20% de pelotas
anaranjadas para
mejor esto veamos una simulación que
hace justamente lo que acabamos de
describir esta simulación fue
desarrollada en el portal de khan
academy con las herramientas en la
sección de programación y fue escrita
por charlotte aguán esta simulación
construye una distribución muestral en
esta parte podemos determinar la
proporción de la población en este caso
vamos a ver las pelotas verdes en lugar
de las pelotas anaranjadas y digamos que
la proporción es del 40% el tamaño de la
muestra es de 10 pelotas y primero
tomemos una sola muestra para tener una
muestra tomamos 10 de estas pelotas y
contamos cuántas de ellas son verdes en
esta primera muestra de 10 pelotas vemos
que 12 3 de ellas son verdes de todos
los resultados posibles vemos que esta
muestra que obtuvimos está en esta parte
pues tres de las diez pelotas que
obtuvimos fueron verdes si queremos ver
la proporción en lugar del conteo damos
clic en el botón de porcentaje aquí ya
tenemos un caso en el que el 30% de las
pelotas fueron verdes
no queremos sólo una muestra sino muchas
así que sigamos obteniendo muestras en
esta nueva muestra tenemos 50 por ciento
de pelotas verdes aquí abajo tenemos una
muestra con 50% ya teníamos una de 60%
tomemos otra muestra y tenemos que el 30
por ciento de las pelotas son verdes
tenemos dos situaciones con 30% de color
verde hacemos esto muchas veces y lo que
creamos aquí es una distribución
muestral si hacemos esto un número
infinito de veces obtendremos la
distribución muestral real de la
proporción de la muestra dada la
proporción de la población que es verde
ya tenemos 77 muestras observa que 20 de
las 77 muestras tuvieron 50% de las
pelotas de color verde sólo una de las
muestras tuvo 80% de pelotas verdes y si
tomamos muchas muestras más en el
simulador podemos tomar hasta 50
muestras cada vez aumentamos esto y
ahora noten que tenemos 15 muestras con
0% de pelotas verdes
tenemos 94 muestras del total de 2.250
con el 10 por ciento de pelotas verdes
podemos transformar cada una de estas
cantidades 23 127 304 etcétera en
porcentajes al dividirlas entre el
número de muestras espero que con esto
tengan una mejor idea de cómo es
diferente una distribución muestral de
una distribución de probabilidad en una
distribución muestral se toman muestras
de una población se calculan
estadísticas de cada muestra y cuando
gráfica moss la distribución muestral
tenemos las diferentes probabilidades de
los resultados de las estadísticas que
se calcularon para dichas muestras nos
vemos en otro vídeo